we've spent a lot of time already
thinking about markets for the goods and
services that firms produce now we're
going to talk about the markets for the
factors of production
often known as the factor
markets what are those factors of
production well we've talked about them
multiple times things like land labor
capital and in particular we're going to
focus in this video on labor
so what we have here are some axes where
the vertical axis is labeled the wage
rate you could view that as the price of
labor it'd be per unit time and on the
horizontal axis in both of these cases
we have the quantity of labor which
would be the number of workers in say
that that unit of time and what we're
going to do on the right
hand side right here is think about it
from the point of view of a firm and
then on the left hand side we're going
to think about it from the point of view
of the market as a whole
and to understand it first on the firm's
point of view we can think about the
demand from a firm how much is a how
much benefit is a firm getting when it
hires that incremental worker and to do
that we're going to think about
something called marginal revenue
product now marginal revenue product
sounds very fancy but i'm going to set
up a little table here so that we can
understand it in reasonable terms so
let's say that this is our labor union
i'm going to set up several columns here
this is how much product
the firm can produce based on the number
of labor units then you have the
marginal product of labor which is for
each incremental unit of labor how much
more are you able to produce so we make
some columns here
and i'm going to add more columns in a
little bit
so let's say we could have zero units of
labor one unit of labor two units of
labor
when you have zero units you're
definitely going to produce zero units
in that time period let's say when you
have one unit of labor one worker in the
time period you're able to produce two
when you have that second labor or that
second worker you're now able to produce
six and so we can think about the
marginal product of labor that first
that first worker is able to produce an
incremental two we went from zero to two
but that second worker by adding them
now you're able to produce an
incremental three units and so here this
might be due to specialization things
like that but over time you might have
diminishing marginal products of labor
but then if you want to think about
what's the real benefit to the firm it's
not just what is being produced but how
much the firm can get for that so we
could think about the marginal revenue
and so let's just say that that is i
don't know four dollars
and it's just a constant four dollars
and then we could think about the
marginal
revenue product which is just going to
be the marginal product of labor times
the amount of dollars or incremental
amount of dollars per unit so it's just
going to be 2 times 4 here which is just
going to be 8
so one way to think about it when the
firm goes from zero laborers or zero
workers to one worker you're going to
have an incremental eight dollars of
revenue based on what that worker can
produce and then when you add another
worker you get three times four you get
an incremental twelve dollars of revenue
and so we can graph this and as i said
sometimes you might say initially you
could get some benefits of
specialization but then over time you
get diminishing returns so it might look
something like this
typically in an econ class you'll just
see a downward sloping line for
simplicity
but the firm's
marginal
revenue
product you can view it as that
individual firm's demand for labor at
those first few units of labor it has a
very high marginal revenue product but
over time you have diminishing returns
from adding more and more people onto
the staff
now how would this look at the market
well what you could do is you could add
up all the marginal revenue products
from all the firms in the market and if
you add them up you're going to get a
market labor demand curve and let me do
this in a slightly different color if
you add all of these up you are going to
get something
like this let me write that out that is
the market
market
labor
demand
demand
curve
now what is going to be the reasonable
level of labor quantity both in the
market and how much would be rational
for this firm to hire well to think
about that we think about the market
labor supply curve and i'm going to
focus on the market first and just like
the market for most things the higher
the wage you're going to have more folks
willing to participate in that labor
market so at a low wage not a lot of
people are going to want to work in this
industry but as wages get higher and
higher
well then more and more people are going
to be up for participating in this labor
market and so this right over here is
the market
labor
supply curve
supply
curve
and so what would be the equilibrium
price of labor which was really just the
wage rate
well it's where your supply and demand
curves intersect and we've seen this
multiple times already so this is i'll
just call that
wage star like that and then the
equilibrium quantity of labor we could
just call that q star right over here
now how would that impact what's going
on in the firm
well if we assume that this is a
perfectly competitive labor market we'll
assume that this firm can't set the wage
it's just going to have to pay people
whatever the equilibrium wage actually
is
and so this right over here
is going to be the firm's what's known
as marginal factor cost
the cost per incremental unit of labor
that's just the wage it's going to have
to pay it can get as much of that labor
as it as we need we assume because we're
talking about a we're talking about a
perfectly competitive labor market in
this industry i'm just trying to draw a
straighter line so this right over here
is our marginal
factor
cost and so you could imagine what is
the rational quantity for this firm to
hire
it would keep hiring all the way until
the incremental revenue per unit of
labor it gets is no longer higher than
the incremental cost of that labor and
that would happen right over here
so this would tell us the rational
quantity of labor i'll call that
quantity for i'll call it q star for the
firm
right over there
i'll leave you there now the important
thing to realize this seems similar to
what we've seen before when we talked
about things like marginal revenue and
marginal cost for a firm's goods but
here we're talking about a firm's inputs
and so instead of it being the marginal
revenue and the price in a perfectly
competitive firm that is defined by the
equilibrium price
here it is the firm's cost that is
defined by the equilibrium wage in the
market